all right well when it comes to finding
that perfect family car you also have to
keep your pets in mind Subaru of Las
Vegas the sponsors of this next segment
share what they are doing to keep our
furry friends safe
we are back at Subaru of Las Vegas with
our friend Burton Hughes and we're
talking all things cars but also we're
talking about families and our furry
family members Burton October is an
important month because it's all about
the pets and here at Subaru you guys
really love the pets but let's talk
about what's important to look for when
you're shopping for a car and you're
considering your furry four-legged
friends at home well you need it you
need help obviously a nice vehicle
that's got the room for it we've got
great SUVs and and and Subaru is a very
dog pet friendly brand and they've got
an entire line of accessories to keep
your pets safe and that is so important
I can't I can't stress enough how you
know driving down the highway when you
see somebody's dog hanging out the
window or hanging out the sunroof or
even out the back it looks cute but it
is so not safe and you know personally
my daughter got into an accident on the
freeway in her Outback where somebody
hit her and she rolled three times both
her and her dog were strapped in and
they both walked away it's so important
to think about that yeah so you highly
advise getting the right equipment
having those things in mind when you're
driving the car and taking your pets
along for the ride right absolutely all
right well coming up in just a few days
is a special national holiday but you
guys are celebrating the pets all month
long tell us about that so Subaru
obviously Subaru loves pets but they
they created a very special date it's
October 22nd and it is National make a
dog's day and they really want people to
think about their pets think about the
animal shelters that might need some
supplies or volunteers and it's a great
day to adopt maybe an underdog some some
animal that maybe would be passed over
you know on a normal basis yeah you guys
are very involved in the community and
always thinking of ways that you can
give back and in addition to all of that
October is also Halloween you guys have
a special Halloween event coming up it's
the third annual one right it's the
third annual it is Subaru of Las Vegas
Halloween hounds and strut your mutt
festival with Michael's Angel Paws
they're a great organ organization that
that trains animals to be therapy dogs
and and so it's just a great thing it's
going to feature the strut your mutt
walk and fall festival and there's going
to be uh animals you can adopt it's just
going to be a lot of fun food trucks you
got to come out and check it out and
really quickly tell us about this car
behind us this is a great option for
families for throwing your pets in the
back yes this is our Ascent Subaru
Ascent is our largest SUV it is a three
row so you can fit up to eight
passengers depending on the seat
configuration and it is a one a great
choice if you've got animals so you know
come on check it out we've got some
great financing still available through
the end of the month uh as low as 2.9
financing on select 2022 and 2023 models
thank you to Findlay Subaru of Las Vegas
for sponsoring the segment call
702-495-2100 for more special offer is
2.9 financing for well-qualified buyers
for up to 48 months on select 2022
models we'll be right back